[Música]
[Aplausos]
para ti
jajaja
recuerdo la primera vez que puse un pie
en esta universidad se celebraba la expo
udlap y en esa edición contaban con mi
banda favorita decir que era mi banda
favorita creo que es muy poco porque esa
playera que está ahí lo hice con
pinturas vinci
ese día cumplí un sueño muy grande el de
ver ya en vivo y conocer a mi banda
favorita pero también me llevé uno más
grande el de regresar a esta universidad
y el día de hoy tengo el placer de estar
parado frente a ustedes también quiero
mandarle un saludo a los allison que el
día de hoy son muy buenos amigos míos y
de repente me hacen burla de cuando le
pedí a esta clase de fotos
los sueños crecen evolucionan y caminan
por y caminan con nosotros pero que tan
dispuestos
estamos a entregarlo todos para que se
realice que tan pacientes tenemos que
ser para no abandonar y quedarnos a
medio camino
hace un par de años la situación
económica en mi casa no estaba bien a
pesar de que yo comencé a trabajar desde
muy chico para aportar a mi casa las
cosas no mejoraban hubo un momento en el
que mi mamá y yo no sabíamos qué hacer
para rescatar el barco y recuerdo un día
en el que llegó y me dijo hijo solo
tenemos 50 pesos para terminar la
quincena entre la desesperación y el
llanto de mi madre
recuerdo que simplemente la abracé y le
dije eres la mejor mamá del mundo tomé
el dinero y les dije a mis hermanos que
me acompañaran y caminamos hasta una
tienda de abarrotes donde compramos
jamón compramos cebolla compramos tortas
y preparamos las mejores tortas del
mundo me parece súper temprano como las
4 de la mañana y caminé hasta una
terminal de autobuses
creo que exagere un poco porque llegué
tan temprano que todas no quería ni
desayunar pero me esperé hasta que no me
queda ninguna torta
se vendieron las tortas y seguimos
vendiendo durante algunas semanas hasta
que algún vivo se le ocurrió ir a vender
burritos y por la novedad ya no eran las
tortas eran los burritos entonces nos
dimos cuenta que teníamos que cambiar la
estrategia a mi mamá se le ocurrió
vender gelatinas de yogur todos nos
dijimos que estábamos de acuerdo porque
le quedaban muy ricas y dijimos ok vamos
a hacerlo aunque nos costaba un poquito
más que las tortas las preparamos las
hicimos con mucha ilusión y recuerdo que
al otro día mi hermano me iba a
acompañar a venderla y también estaba yo
emocionado que mi hermanito formará
parte y que viera lo que lo que es
ganarse el dinero nos paramos temprano
puse las gelatinas en una charola salí
con ella y al salir de mi casa me
encontré con mi vecina que estaba
teniendo su ropa y recuerdo que me
barrio de arriba abajo y me dijo yamile
no te da pena vender gelatinas en la
calle sin ningún filtro y sin pensarlo
yo simplemente le contesté por mi
familia haría lo que sea no quería
perder más el tiempo con personas que no
valían la pena porque tenía algo más
importante y era acabar
gelatinas mi hermano y yo caminamos
hasta una rotonda de la unidad
habitacional donde vivía comenzamos a
ofrecer las gelatinas a la gente que
pasaba a la gente que regresaba a la
gente que se bajaba del camión y no
vendíamos ni una sola gelatina yo me
comencé a desesperar y le dije vamos a
tocar casa por casa tocamos puerta tras
puerta tras puerta tras puerta habían
pasado varias horas y no habíamos
vendido nada
nunca voy a olvidar el nudo en la
garganta y la potencia que sentí cuando
mi hermanito de 10 años me dijo yamile
tengo hambre no tenía dinero no tenía
nada no tenía comida en el refrigerador
simplemente me intenté hacer el fuerte
lo abracé y le dije mira a las 12 ya lo
vamos a tener ni una gelatina nos
animamos y seguimos tocando seguimos
tocando y seguimos tocando hasta que
tocamos una casa y vendimos la primera
gelatina y mi hermano y yo festejamos
como si hubiéramos anotado un gol en el
minuto 89 la final de la champions
tocamos la siguiente casa y vendimos
otra gelatina atacamos la tercera casa y
que creen que pasó no vendimos la
siguiente pero en la cuarta casa si
vendimos en eso escuché que me cifraron
voltee irnos nos llamaban de la primera
casa yo regresé atendía el llamado era
la señora y me dijo oye cuando gelatinas
te quedan me cagan como unas diez once y
me dijo están muy ricas me quedo todas
cuando pronunció estas palabras recuerdo
que me sentí como en las películas
cuando algún soldado le estalló una
bomba sentí que todo estaba en cámara
lenta tomé el dinero camine y en la
entrada había mi hermanito
simplemente lo abrace con todas mis
fuerzas y me dijo que aquí pasó cuando
esté con perdón y le dije ya las
vendimos todas lo abracé muy fuerte y
recuerdo que me dijo eres un mentiroso y
hoy creo que soy un mentiroso y me dijo
si dijiste que las íbamos a vender a las
12 y son doce y media entre risas y
bromas nos regresamos a mi casa y todos
felices pasamos muy bien ese día y
seguimos vendiendo vendiendo las
gelatinas a los 18 años te quieres comer
el mundo quiere salir con tus amigos
tiene salir de parranda quiere salir de
antro quieres el celular que está de
moda quieres la ropa que está de moda de
la tienda de moda pero todos tenemos una
historia diferente que contar la mía se
convirtió en universidad por las mañanas
en trabajar por las tardes hacer tarea
por las noches y los fines de semana le
pedí trabajo admitió enrique que tenía
un café internet donde trabajaba yo el
fin de semana para poder ganar unos
pesos más
de repente por más optimista que
intentaba hacer me cerraba mi cuarto y
decía por qué me pasa esto a mí porque
no puedo estar ahorita tomando con mis
amigos que están en cholula porque no
puedo estar viajando de repente irse a
algún lado porque me tiene que pasar
esto a mí a esa edad no lo comprendes tú
simplemente quieres hacer lo que los
demás hacen
en los ratos libres en el café internet
aproveche y descubrir lo que hoy en día
es una de mis pasiones más grandes
el diseño gráfico comencé viendo
tutoriales en youtube un tutorial me
llevó a otro y a otro ya otro ya otro y
fue así como sin darme cuenta había
descubierto mi más grande pasión
un día dije bueno si veo tantos vídeos
porque no abro mi canal y así es que me
descubrí me decidí a abrirlo yo ni
siquiera sabía que había youtubers yo ni
siquiera sabía que se ganaba dinero yo
simplemente lo hice porque quería
distraerme de algo de todo lo que hacía
del día comencé con mi canal comencé con
un tripié casero hecho con tubos de pvc
y con la que ahora de mi celular y yo
dije ok yo no tengo la oportunidad de
tener una cámara réflex una cámara algo
no tengo ni un iphone para que se vea
padre puesto que yo tengo las
herramientas y tengo el conocimiento que
ya ha adquirido con los tutoriales para
hacer diseños y hacerlo más bonito cada
vez los vídeos les iba un poquito mejor
al principio la neta solo los veía a mi
mamá y mis amigos amigos que por cierto
me hacían burla cuando comenzaba con los
vídeos y era bastante curioso como
después de unos meses ya no eran burlas
y era como oye me gusta tu vídeo y lo
compartí y después amigos de los amigos
vi que un amigo compartió un vídeo toyo
y lo y lo compartí porque me gustó
fue bastante curioso como la pasión se
empezó a volver una una obsesión yo
estaba concentrado y quería hacer mejor
las cosas sin importar que no tuviera
los medios económicos para lograrlo
me di cuenta que no tenía tiempo de
quejarme que lo que tenía que hacer era
ocuparme no se trata de quién eres y que
tienes hoy se trata de quién quiere ser
mañana que tome los productos los
problemas por los cuernos que te aferres
y que con mucho esfuerzo te sacrificas
para que un día la vida no tenga más más
que entregarte lo
esta es mi primera computadora me regaló
mi papá con mucho esfuerzo y recuerdan
que les dije que era yo muy fan de
allison pues que creen si lo soy tengo
hasta aquí una estampa
no me encontraba con esta computadora
desde
hace unos cinco años y no puedo creer
como diseñada y exportaba acá y como
aguantó y es por eso que un día falleció
la explota de más y pues bueno no
pudimos continuar en ese tiempo la
situación no estaba tan bien como para
que yo llegara con un sopas y les dijera
necesita una computadora y también había
otras prioridades lo que se me ocurrió
hacer fue pedir permiso en la
universidad y me prestaban una
computadora de un laboratorio de repente
había clases y me tenía que salir porque
no podía estar el salón lo aprovechaba
para hacer tareas o de repente iratzarri
está the food regresaba para seguir
diseñando lo que tuviera que hacer o
editar hasta que me dieran las 9 de la
noche que era el transporte de la
escuela y si no y si no tomaba me tenía
que quedar cuando eso pasaba amigo a la
casa de un primo y que dejó de subir ahí
porque ya no había alcanzado el autobús
la vida no es como un libro de paulo
coelho no le das vuelta y ya la vida
cambió de repente fueron tiempos de
mucha lucha de mucho sacrificio y que al
final el mi pasión por el diseño se fue
propagando y el trabajo fue el que habló
por sí solo le di las gracias a mi tío
en el internet ya era un trabaje ahí di
las gracias en la lavandería donde
trabajaba porque esto se estaba
volviendo cada vez más real y eran más
sustentables
comencé a trabajar las vistas en mis
vídeos empezaron a seguir de repente
empecé a colaborar en canales de youtube
de los más grandes de méxico y de habla
hispana un día recibí una llamada la
tomé y me dijeron oye mira tenemos una
vacante mi empresa por cierto era una de
las empresas más importantes en su
tiempo y trabajaban con personas de
internet que tenían millones y millones
de seguidores y mi trabajo se va a
exponer pues a más personas
cuando eso pasó
tuve miedo y comenzaron las excusas yo
dije pero es que yo no soy diseñador yo
soy ingeniero todavía estoy acabando la
carrera no déjame pensarlo lo pensé y lo
medite y no sé ustedes pero yo creo que
las mamás tienen un sentido arácnido un
día estaba yo mi computadora trabajando
y sin darme cuenta de mi mamá estaba
atrás de mí
ese día no sé cuánto tiempo llevaba ahí
pero llevaba viendo 60 junto a mí como
mi mano y me dijo hijo tienes que volar
en ese momento eran las palabras que
estaba buscando me dijo voy a intentarlo
no pierdes nada la universidad va a
estar acá nosotros vamos a estar acá
porque no lo intentas porque no quiero
que vivas con la idea del qué hubiera
pasado si fue así cómo fue lo que
esperaba tome mi celular le marque a de
la empresa y le dije si acepto el
trabajo colgué y dije ah
y donde voy a vivir
me metía mosca rentas y dije no ni
siquiera el dinero que tengo le hable a
uno de mis amigos que hoy en día es una
de las personas más importantes de mi
vida y le dije
y tomé la decisión me voy a ir
él me dijo 20 aquiles bien recibido
sabes que te amamos tenemos una litera
en la sala y te puedes quedar ahí no sé
por qué hay una litera la sala analizará
la sala y ahí viví un año y comenzó a
trabajar fuerte está yo solamente llegué
con mi computadora con una maleta pero
con un chingo de ganas de ser el mejor
por primera vez en mi vida me sentía en
el lugar correcto
cada día más personas vieron mi trabajo
cada vez que empecé a colaborar en más
canales cada vez empezó a trabajar con
marcas que en mi vida pensé que iba a
colaborar con ellas y en ningún momento
alguien me dijo a ver tu título eres
diseñador gráfico eres productor en
ningún momento les importaba mi trabajo
y la calidad del
el trabajo se fue abriendo camino y un
día recibí una llamada que a mis 17 años
que era imposible que sólo hacía a la
gente rica me dijeron oye queremos que
vayas a cubrir un evento a ámsterdam es
uno de festivales de música electrónica
más importante del mundo y fue como ok
voy a cruzar el charco no lo podía creer
y este soy yo muy feliz
la foto está desenfocada porque un amigo
no las olvida todas por tomar pero ese
soy yo muy feliz en ámsterdam
el trabajo llamo más trabajo y seguir
colaborando visite más estados en la
república conocí a otros lugares trabajé
con gente que siempre admiré desde que
el amor
y no vengo a hablarles del éxito que
tuvo ya mil en sus redes sociales en
youtube de que la rompió durísimo no les
vengo a hablar de lo que esto trajo a mi
vida
después de dos años de trabajo intenso
hubo un solo error en la ecuación
cualquier cual creen que fue
pues querer llenar los vacíos
emocionales de mi pasado deseas aumentar
tu malteada porque si 20 pesos más no
cuesta nada decía deseas volver
hamburguesa extra jumbos y hagamos lo
cual es lo más caro del menú así pide lo
comencé a darme cuenta que como dice
shakira aumente más de 3 kilos
este era yo
me sentía atrapado dentro de mi propio
cuerpo tenía seguidores en redes
sociales y me sentía con la necesidad de
fingir ser alguien que no era me daba
pena salir de mi cuarto salir a la calle
que me pidiera una foto y que me
encontraran y me vieran así subía fotos
con photoshop porque quería enmascarar
una persona que no era un día media me
había el espejo y me di cuenta que el
photoshop no lo puedes poner en él
tenía que hacer algo me di cuenta que
había trabajado toda mi vida y ya que
estaba acá estaba a punto de cometer el
error más garrafal de ella
porque le tenemos miedo a mostrarnos
como somos en redes sociales en ese
momento me di cuenta que las cosas no
estaban bien que tenía poner tenía que
poner manos a la obra y tomé mi cámara
como una vez la puse me senté grabé un
vídeo siendo yo y diciendo lo que sentía
así como lo hacían las personas que
hacían vídeos en esas épocas y no
estaban enfocados en ser un producto
cuando lo subí me dio mucho miedo y
estuve a punto de eliminarlo me di
cuenta que hay muchas personas y que el
internet de repente es muy malo cuando
me siente la computadora para eliminarlo
me di cuenta que tenía más de 300.000
vistas y que los comentarios eran
positivos que si había uno que otro niño
rata que estaba ahí pero la mayoría de
los comentarios era de que me sentí muy
identificado dijiste las palabras
adecuadas llevo muchos años sintiéndome
así yo lo logré yo lo pude superar lo
puedes hacer en ese momento me di cuenta
que no estaba solo y encontré el
verdadero valor de las redes sociales el
compartir y tener un contenido en esto
si quieres ganar vídeo a internet lo
puedes hacer lo podemos hacer
actualmente pero realmente que le estás
compartiendo a la gente que te ve y te
sigue
en ese momento en el que me percaté que
las cosas no estaban bien recordé cuando
empecé recordé cuando llegué a mis
primeros 100 seguidores y lo que sentía
recordé cuando tuve que ahorrar para
comprar mi primer gol
cuando tuve que sacrificar y me di
cuenta ahora que lo que se estaba
haciendo real y que muchos no creyeron
en ellos yo lo estaba desperdiciando
todos necesitamos saber que hay una luz
y una mano que se extiende al final del
túnel
actualmente yo sé que no me dio su
perfil pero he perdido 17 kilos he
compartido este contenido en redes
sociales no que la intención de ser
presentados o alardear de ello sino
porque nunca me espere tuviera muchas
personas que se sumarán invisible y
recibir estos mensajes no sólo de mexico
de ecuador de latinoamerica incluso de
otros países
recuerdan de la mano que les conté que
se extiende al final del túnel él es una
de las personas más importantes de mi
vida y muchas veces me extendió la su
mano desde que llegó y me dijo quédate
en la litera de mi casa festejamos este
año que pasó mis 25 años guys 25
primaveras el madrid en uno de los
lugares que nunca creí conocer en mi
vida recuerdo que mi primo y yo jugamos
en el patio de su casa a que era el
santiago bernabéu y ahí estaba yo
de pie en el santiago bernabéu
sintiéndome una hormiga con lo
majestuoso que era alce la cara y al
mismo tiempo me sentí un gigante
en ese momento cayeron en mi mente de
todos los porqués a mis 18 años porque
el trabajo porque sacrificar en ese
momento encontré todas las respuestas y
me sentí muy muy aliviado aparte que
estaba donde jugó que sea ronaldo claro
aprendí a quererme a respetarme a
valorar mi cuerpo mi trabajo y todo lo
que ha conllevado y sobre todo
encontrarle la responsabilidad a las
redes sociales así tengas 10 seguidores
2050 tú tienes la responsabilidad de
inspirar y de sembrar algo en alguien
puedes abrir el nombre de una persona
pero no su historia
puedes haber escuchado lo que ha hecho
pero no lo que ha pasado
les juro que hay calma después de la
tormenta es cuestión de echarle muchas
ganas de mucho sacrificio
de chingar le mucho de confiar en ti
mismo porque nadie más lo va a ser la fe
y la confianza mueven montañas
y también viene gelatinas yo soy a mi
rey gracias
[Aplausos]